das weiß sein kann es gerne mitnehmen
hat sie sprechen mit ihnen sprechen
ich möchte mich nicht nicht leuten
auseinander setzen
die mich tot sehen wollen also ich mach
ich das sprechen wir starten direkt mit
der ersten frage von 13 fragen mit
unserer konflikt frage führte
identitätspolitik zu einer gerechteren
gesellschaft wenn ihr sagt ja führt sie
dann geht das grüne feld und wenn ihr
sagt nein sich spaltet unsere
gesellschaft dann geht er aufs gelbe
fällt identitätspolitik das ist auf den
ersten blick ein großer komplizierter
begriff dabei ist es eigentlich ganz
einfach es geht um gruppen in unserer
gesellschaft die auf verschiedene art
und weise benachteiligt sind diese
betonen laut ihre identität also
merkmale wie geschlecht herkunft oder
hautfarbe
der grund dass sie wollen gehört
anerkannt und gleichberechtigt werden
die frage ist es das der richtige weg um
gleichberechtigung für alle zu erreichen
oder spaltet identitätspolitik unsere
gesellschaft sogar noch mehr
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare was
ihr dazu denkt es ist nicht selten
passiert dass menschen ihre meinung nach
unseren folgen geändert haben dann heißt
es für euch ab jetzt wenn ihr ein
argument der gegenseite zustimmen wollt
dann geht er einen schritt auf die
andere seite zu und wenn ihr vielleicht
sogar sauer seit während jemand anders
sagt um das zum ausdruck bringen wollt
dann geht er einen schritt nach hinten
ich möchte mit dir staaten emilia lass
uns noch mal über diesen komplexen
begriff identitätspolitik sprechen was
für einen sinn steckt eigentlich
dahinter identitätspolitik ist
eigentlich nichts anderes als bewegungen
für die befreiung von unterdrückten
menschen
und deswegen gibt es das gefühl dass es
die gesellschaft spaltet weil es trigger
testträger die menschen die bisher über
die macht verfügt haben und es gibt
einen spruch das heißt dass menschen die
bisher privilegiert waren empfinden
gleichberechtigung wie diskriminierung
das thema liegt mir am herzen weil ich
mich für eine
echte welt engagieren will weil ich
möchte nicht mehr schweigen ich mache
das für mich für die generation
informiert und für die generationen nach
mehr
es ist möglich in eine untere kunst
freie welt anzukommen einfach nur wenn
die kollektiv mutig sind dafür kann
identitätspolitik nur von minderheiten
kommen
ja weil es ist auf keinen fall möglich
zum beispiel die white power oder die
neonazi bewegung mit identitäts
politischen bewegungen von minderheiten
zu vergleichen da spielten sich auch die
meinungen oder also es gibt auch
expertin ja aber ich würde sagen zum
beispiel neonazis also ihr ziel ist eben
die überlegenheit der weißen rasse zu
proklamieren und minderheiten zu
unterdrückung bis hin zu vernichten und
zum beispiel die blätter bewegung oder
die miete bewegung das ziel ist nicht
andere zu unterdrücken ganz und gar
nicht sondern es geht darum
gleichberechtigung gleichheit
sichtbarkeit und respekt zu gewinnen
also stetig quasi ja nicht bei
minderheit bleiben weil es geht für mich
eher um macht und die historische
komponente ist es geht um politische
mehrheit und politischer minderheit zb
frauen sind statistisch gesehen auch in
der mehrheit und dennoch weil sie über
weniger macht über weniger zugang zu
ressourcen über weniger deutungshoheit
sehen sie in der minderheit
also lieh man den begriff minderheit
genau versteht wieso brauchen wir denn
deiner meinung nach emilia
identitätspolitik für den kampf um
gleichberechtigung weil dessen befreiung
geht es wie ist es denn möglich über
rassismus zu sprechen ohne über die
betroffenen menschen zu sprechen
wer ist es denn möglich über behinderten
wendigkeit zu sprechen ohne die stimmen
von behinderten menschen in der
vordergrund zu stellen
das gleiche gilt für frauen für ngp zwei
gruppen
deswegen ist es ist unerlässlich und das
ist nicht identitätspolitik die spaltet
sondern es sieht der widerstand dagegen
ich wollte euch gerade fragen ob er
einen schritt auf die milliarden geht
aber ihr seid alle ein schritt auf sie
zugegangen sein warum bist du auf sie
zugegangen
man kann die unterdrückung gewisse
personen natürlich nicht behandeln ohne
sun tzu anzusprechen welche gruppen
unterdrückt werden ich finde
identitätspolitik kann bis zu einem
gewissen grad schon hilfreich sein um
auf gewisse themen aufmerksam zu machen
aber wenn es zu extrem betrieben wird
dann heißt dann zum beispiel weil man
ein weißer heterosexuelles mann ist dass
man zu manchen themen gar nicht mehr die
meinung sagen darf und das trägt
natürlich dazu bei dass die meinung ein
bisschen eingeschränkt wird aber was
mich interessieren wie du hast du ganz
ganz am anfang so was gesagt die die
weiße bevölkerung oder so was sie die
macht hat die sind triggert wenn man
ausspricht
das dass sie die macht haben und die
sind dagegen würdest du sagen weil ich
weiß bin habe ich macht über dich oder
wie oder wen meinst mit die weißen die
die macht haben wir leben in einer
gesellschaft die so strukturiert ist das
weiß sein ganz oben in der hierarchie
gestellt ist deshalb du hast keine macht
über mich so direkt individuell gesehen
aber gesellschaftlich gesehen weiße
menschen verfügen über diese macht sie
verfügen über die macht in den medien in
der politik im bildungssystem in allen
bereichen des gesellschaftlichen lebens
aber aber in deutschland ist es ja
logisch dass mehr weiße menschen gibt es
nur weil es logisch ist also müsst jetzt
das quasi jetzt zum beispiel der
regierung gleich viel weiße und schwarze
sind obwohl es viel weniger weiß er viel
weniger schwarze gibt da geht es ja um
wie vieles was in meiner macht mehr
macht haben als andere personengruppen
und es geht ich glaube es geht ja nicht
darum wie viele menschen wo sind sondern
wie viel mehr kannst du machen selbst
wenn dein name hättest der teil einer
priviligierten gruppe wäre dann hast du
die macht desto mehr wohnungen bekommen
kannst als die andere person und das ist
etwas was du auch womit man auch
profitieren kann und was man auch
benutzen kann
das ist nicht so ich verprügelt dich
jetzt sondern das sind subtilere dinge
individuum 8 aus obst ich glaube das
sogenannte identitätspolitik uns dabei
helfen kann die bedürfnisse der
einzelnen menschen irgendwie besser
anzugehen
und wenn du genau weißt was diese person
gerade durchlebt oder was vielleicht
kollektive erfahrungen sind die das
leben schwieriger machen dann kann man
es auch leichter verbessern das leben
dieser person wohl bedacht da nicht die
macht aus du bist vielleicht aktiv keine
macht aus aber der fakt ist dass du
privilegiert ist vom system ab und
einige aspekt aber nicht wieder an alle
aspekte also ich meine jeder von uns ist
eine seite privilegierte und andere
seite nicht privilegiert ich habe einen
schritt nach vorne gemacht
wenn du merken gesagt hast denn das geht
um machte das ist der punkt aber das hat
mit identität nichts zu tun oder
zumindest ist nicht die
identitätspolitik die lösung wenn ich
zum beispiel über meine eigene identität
spreche das ist ein preis macht wie die
identität von iris mensch ich habe
verschiedene facetten ich bin eine frau
eine sizilianer in eine italienerin aber
keine von diese etikette bestimmte meine
werte und beschreibt mich als ganz
person wenn ich zu einer gruppe
angehören das heißt du braucht nicht
dass ich dieselbe werte teile von den
andere leute die in derselben gruppe
sind eine frau zu sein heißt nicht
feministin zu sein zum beispiel ich bin
für minister habe es ging ja es gibt
ganz viele frauen die für eine
patriarchale strukturen der gesellschaft
sind und ich teile meine feministischer
perspektive mit viele männer zum
beispiel warum führt sie denn deiner
meinung nach zu mehr ausgrenzung weil
sie steckte die leute in schubladen
kategorie die immer zu eng sind weil
jeder von uns hat verschiedene
identitäten ja habe ich nur eine
identität und das heißt ich möchte mit
den leute kämpfen die meine gleiche
politische werte teilen und nicht auch
von italiener vertreten werde zum
beispiel weil es gibt ganz viele
italiener die politische werte vertreten
die ganz andere sind aus meiner also
dieses laut identität betonen sich ich
sag jetzt möchte ich jetzt mal in
kategorien einordnen das findest du
nicht gut und geraubt nicht gut
würde mich auch interessieren was ihr
dazu denkt müssen wir gruppen
identitäten überhaupt erst mal sichtbar
machen also frauen menschen mit
behinderung bei pcs homosexuelle
menschen um überhaupt erst mal
klarzustellen dass diese überhaupt
diskriminiert werden
doch ich muss sagen es geht ja auch gar
nicht darum dich oder jemand anderen zu
beschränken in der identität natürlich
ist deine identität nicht damit geklärt
dass du sagst ich bin eine frau
natürlich haben wir alle viel mehr
facetten oder so aber auch du als die
ministerin wenn du in feministischen
kampfes oder verfügen feministische
werte politisch was vertritt oder so
dann ob dies wollen oder nicht oder ob
dieses wissen oder nicht dann kämpfst du
auch für die frauen die sich nicht als
für mindesten betrachten oder so genau
weil weil ich weil ich kein fall für
universelle rechte und nicht für
besondere rechte viel besser und der
kategorie geht ja nicht um gesunde
brachte es geht um gleichberechtigung
mir persönlich liegt das thema sehr am
herzen denn wir leben in einer
gesellschaft die sexistisch die
rassistisch sozialisiert ist und es
besteht ein ungleichgewicht ein
machtgefälle es ist fakt dass gewisse
gruppen von menschen unterdrückt werden
und das system andere leute klar
bevorteilt
und wenn wir gerechtigkeit wollen dann
müssen wir das ändern ich glaube das ist
eine sehr reduzierende art und weise
identitätspolitik zu sehen weil das
heißt im grunde so ganz pauschal wir
sehen ok alle frei müssen so denken alle
männer so müssen so denken das geht
überhaupt nicht darum identitätspolitik
den befreiungsbewegungen die gegen
systeme die gegen unterdrückung systeme
vorgehen das heißt feminismus ist
identitätspolitik und das geht vor dem
patriarchen also es gibt gegen dem
patriarchat vor
die antifa sie waren bedeutung man
bezeichnest du feminismus aus einer
identitätspolitik weil sie diskutieren
heute über die zinspolitik und das ist
im grunde eine befreiungsbewegung wie
ich gerade gesagt habe ist die arbeiter
bewegung für dich eine identitäts
bewegung die bewegung für die rechte der
arbeitnehmer das ist in diesem sinne
es sind alle identitäten die auf uns
projiziert werden klasse ist auch eine
identität die auf uns projiziert wird
klasse ist wie wir uns einziehen
was sie essen wie wir sprechen dass wir
tragen getragen dass auch in uns und
deshalb ein stück weit kann dir auch
trotzdem von einer identitätspolitik
sprechen aber ich spreche lieber von
befreiungsbewegungen ich will aber schon
ein geschehen ist gibt einen strang oder
es gibt schon menschen die
identitätspolitik sehr undifferenziert
ausüben und die wirklich nur sagen du
musst allen schwarzen glauben und du
musst allen frauen glauben und darüber
und ich sehe solche phrasen auf
instagram ich sehe dass das leute sowas
sagen ich sehe leute das sagen du bist
weißt dara und das ist also ich weiß
wenn du sagst das ist nicht
identitätspolitik aber manche leute
verhalten sich so dass der eindruck
entsteht dass sei identitätspolitik und
ich kann verstehen dass man da ein
widerstand hat und man muss auch
anerkennen
das ist nicht alles so glasklar ist es
gibt immer verschiedene rassen ich kann
jetzt nicht deine erfahrung genau
gleichsetzen mit einer anderen person
nur weil die beiden wurzeln in europa
haben und manchmal passiert ist aber
dann gibt es sales pacers und da könne
man keine weißen rein
aber weil ich jetzt albaner bin habe ich
vielleicht trotzdem diskriminierung
erfahren und das ist etwas was sich
nachvollziehen kann aber ich würde nicht
diese menschen als exemplarischen hinzu
die ganze bewegung heimen du bist gerade
einen schritt auf ihn zugegangen ist
warum du hast ja vorher am anfang bei
dem statement gesagt die leute sind kein
fan der identitätspolitik weil die
beißen wollen 50 getriggert durch das
ganze ich glaube das was er geschrieben
hat das ist eher der grund warum leute
sich triggert füllen von der
identitätspolitik weil es dann auf
einmal heisst ja du bist weißt du darfst
da überhaupt nicht mitreden bei den
ganzen themen weil du bist ja zu wenig
unterdrückt oder sowas ja das glaube ich
ist warum das die meisten leute auf dem
lande oft oder oft übersetzen ist so
vielleicht wird gesagt hey du bist weiß
hast du überhaupt keine erfahrungen mit
rassismus ist es jetzt wichtig dass du
deinen senf dazu abgibt und es kann aber
sein dass manche leute das übersetzen du
verbietet es mir jetzt war ich nicht
unterdrückt genug bin also ich muss auch
sagen manchmal wird auch oft dinge
werden bewusst missverstanden angriff
stimmt also wenn du natürlich jetzt
sagst über deine rassismus erfahrungen
reeders da kann ich natürlich nicht
sagen
die rassismus erfahrungen die hast du
nicht so weil beim 1
keine rassismus erfahren habe dass wir
überhaupt gar keinen sinn ergeben da
kann ich wird er gerne mal auf dich zu
sprechen kommen dass ich gerade das
erste mal bewegt als einer der letzten
sage ich mal anders zu bewerten
warum würdest du denn sagen dass
identitätspolitik aus deiner sicht
wichtig ist identitätspolitik klingt ein
bisschen so nach egoismus
identitätspolitik klingt wissen nach ich
bin das und ihr müsst alle auf mich
hören oder so und darum geht's halt gar
nicht sondern es geht ja auch gar nicht
um jede einzelne individuelle forderung
die irgendein mensch haben soll sondern
es geht da einfach um bewiesene
strukturen und benachteiligungen wo man
sagt das sollte einfach nicht so sein
und will das zu sagen dass
identitätspolitik des erreicht also dass
irgendwann alle alle rechte haben ich
denke es ist notwendig weil irgendwie
muss man ja seine stimme hörbar machen
und das wird wahrscheinlich am ende des
tages ist es politik wenn ich meine
stimme hallo und rechte stimme also
nicht alle leute die in einer gruppe
sind habe in dieser geschichte machen
nein aber es geht doch um es gibt ja
nicht um in dem individuelle erfahrungen
es geht um vorhandene wiesen eine
strukturelle benachteiligung lamey sah
ich würde gerne an was du dazu sagen
möchtest also ich könnte genauso auf
dieser seite stehen also im herzen bin
ich gerührt
für mich persönlich ist das thema
identitätspolitik wichtig weil ich in
diesem land geboren und aufgewachsen bin
und natürlich auch als kind von
migranten auch selbst betroffen bin
und es ist das ergebnis von einer ganz
besonderen generation die es geschafft
hat dass wir heute ja identitätspolitik
betreiben dürfen die aber auch mit
vorsicht zu genießen ist
ich kann die position von sei man auch
sehr gut verstehen wenn er sagt wenn es
anfängt dass ich dann mein wort nicht
dass mein wort keine gewichtung hat oder
ich ausgeschlossen werde
weil ich weiß bin oder aus münchen oder
aus deutschland wie auch immer dann
fängt es dann fangen wir damit an
eigentlich genau mit denselben mitteln
verarbeiten wie die leute die wir
eigentlich versuchen zu bekämpfenden
anführungsstrichen heimen und ich und
alle diese beteiligten personen sind
sind deutschland und sei man darf nicht
ausgeschlossen werden nur weil er das
ist was er isst das ist mein
ausgangssituation nehme mir ja du hast
nicht ein schritt dazu bewegt ja genau
das ist richtig so zu sagen wir dürfen
nicht die gleiche mittel verwenden die
gegen uns verwendet werden also im
grunde und wehrleute sagte kenner des
mentor dem us trio them as trifft es
darum geht es aber ich glaube das ist
eine interpretations trage das heißt
dass viele menschen interpretieren die
tatsache dass minoriten gruppen für die
sprechen und auch sich behaupten und
sich im power als bedrohung und deswegen
sind sie fahren also haben sie in einer
art von defensive haltung dagegen weil
sie unterschwellig und unbewusst das
gefühl haben da kommt rache was würdest
du denn sagen ist deiner meinung nach
der nachteil oder das problem an der
identitätspolitik wenn wir also das ist
das so ein bisschen was sich aus der
social media blase so ein bisschen
beobachten kann es dass menschen
anfangen sich bestimmte themen zu einer
berufung zu machen und dann nur noch
durch diese brille auf die themen
schauen
dies führt dies dient also das ist das
was ich beobachte ich sehe sehr viele
aktivisten oder aktivistinnen die nicht
mehr der sache dienen sondern auch ganz
viel sich selbst dienen und sich damit
etablieren in verschiedenen themen
man sieht immer dieselben figuren
verschiedenen debatten im fernsehen oder
in verschiedenen formaten und dann
wiederum frage ich mich dies führt auch
dazu dass diese diese leute die ihre
karrieren damit machen und auch die so
wie ich die dann abnehmer sind auf der
anderen seite aus dieser nummer nicht
mehr rauskommen also wann können wir
dann eine gemeinsame identität
entwickeln das ist für mich diese frage
die sich stellt da noch sagen also das
problem was so genannt hast das kann ich
verstehen gerade irgendwie in linken
kreisen gibt es irgendwie diesen
wettkampf wer ist locker und wenn dann
jemand einmal etwas falsches gesagt hat
innerhalb des linken spektrums dann wird
dann ist voll der fall die ausfuhren so
anstatt zu sagen es gibt ein bisschen
größere probleme als wer ist am längsten
oder wäre es am besten aber die
strukturelle benachteiligung vor also
oder sexismus es trotzdem echt sei man
warum empfindest du denn unsere aktuelle
debatten kultur als problematisch also
ich vertrete die meinung dass sie mit
allen personen diskutieren soll
und ich bin für eine rege öffentliche
diskussion mit allen menschen und es
herrscht immer mehr so eine meinung von
wegen man darf mit den leuten nicht
reden weil die sind zu recht so so es
gibt so eine aufteilung zwischen gut und
böse und und auch dann kommt direkt die
kontakt schuld so was wie er hat einmal
mit mit dieser person geredet also ist
ja auch rechts und gegen solche sachen
bin ich man sollte da wirklich frei mit
allen diskutieren und man sollte sich
auch immer bewusst sein dass es bei
manchen themen kein richtig oder falsch
gibt natürlich kann man sich auch über
die fakten streiten aber teilweise ist
auch eine sache von unterschiedlichen
prinzipien also wenn sie zum beispiel um
das thema corona oder sowas geht
natürlich kann man sich über die fakten
streiten wie viel bringt welche maßnahme
aber selbst wenn wir uns einig wären bei
den fakten gelbes trotzdem
unterschiedliche meinungen weil die
leute unterschiedliche haltungen zum
thema auf freiheit und gesundheit haben
und hast du manchmal das gefühl dass du
angst hast eine herrliche meinung zu
sagen angst wort geschätzt angenommen
man hat angst vor dem sturm
und auch ganz witzig bevor ich hierher
gekommen bin war ich beim friseur die
die mir die haare geschnitten hat die
bei übertrieben links also das hat man
ihn direkt angesehen und die hat auch
gesagt dass sie sehr links ist und ja
zum beispiel mal eine rede der eines afd
politikers gesehen wo sie eigentlich der
meinung war dass der eigentlich da viele
gute sachen gesagt haben sie hat gesagt
sie hat sich nicht getraut es zu teilen
weil sie hätte angst was ist dann für
folgen hätte dann wird es direkt heißt
du bist jetzt auch rechts weil du das
gepostet hast oder sowas
wenn man ja genau also kurz zu der sache
ist das ding ist meinungen rassismus ist
keine meinung und wenn du im video von
der af details auch wenn er vielleicht
gerade in diesem kontext was gesagt hat
was vielleicht ganz okay es darf man es
niemals ohne den kontext betrachten und
die ard ist eine verzichtes rassistische
nazi partei und in dem moment wo ich mit
jemandem von der afg rede ein video von
der art die teile die biete ich diesen
rassisten eine plattform als weißer als
weiß st
ganz gerne mit neon hat sie sprechen mit
fd wähler und wählerinnen sprechen
ich möchte mich nicht nicht leuten
auseinander setzen
die mich tot sehen wollen als ich noch
nicht das rote haus bringen sprechen
weil das macht mich wirklich also ich
finde das so problematisch das ist
bagatellisiert wird dass sie so auch das
ist eine meinung die eine andere als die
ist urteil des diskurses nein es gab
hier in deutschland einen genozid das
genau auf diese ideen basiert hat meine
vorfahren meine jüdische vorfahren sind
in diesen genozid gestorben und ich
möchte nicht dass diese ideen einfach
als eine meinung ja können wir uns gerne
mit
also mit diesen meinungen auseinander
setzen dann würdest dich nicht
interessieren wie sie zu ihrer position
kommen und wenn diese völlig andere ich
weiß das schon
ich weiß das schon ja ja aber vielleicht
vielleicht könntest du auch ihre
meinungen müssen das ist nicht meine
rolle es ist nicht meine rolle also dich
und gesetzt und schließlich sogar jetzt
nicht quasi männer dass mein großvater
ist wenn du so willst du das board von
fd er war so ganz lange bis zu seinem
tod eine extrem rechte
ich kenne diese meinung ich habe mich
damit neueren oder gesetzt und das ist
nicht in meinem interesse zu versuchen
menschen von einer menschlichkeit zu
überzeugen
ich weiß das ist sehr sehr emotional
aufgeladenes thema deswegen dass es
schwierig manche sachen stehen zu lassen
aber ich habe da ein konkretes beispiel
über das ich mit euch gerne nochmal
genauer sprechen möchte und zwar es gab
jetzt bei der folge zum thema abtreibung
den fall dass hier auf dem feld ein gast
war der hier überhaupt nichts
problematisches gesagt hat aber nach der
veröffentlichung hat sich herausgestellt
dass er das so auf fünf keine masken zu
tragen dass er die krone maßnahmen mit
der politik im nationalsozialismus
gleichstellt also sehr schräge
vergleiche und ein punkt wo das zdf und
diese sendung die redaktion eigentlich
sofort gesagt hätte hätte man das vorher
gewusst
er wäre nicht eingeladen worden also
rote linie das bedauert die redaktion
auch und da stelle ich die frage an euch
wäre das denn richtig dass er die rote
linie ist also muss es grenzen geben wo
sind die grenzen und wer setzt diese
grenzen für mich ist das keine rote
grenze vor allem wenn es gar nicht um
das thema ging es ging ja nicht um das
thema in dem fall um das thema corona
warum
so so so als wäre eine person wenn sie
zu einer sache eine fragwürdige meinung
hat eine person die zu allen themen
fragwürdige meinung hat so das ist eine
person die kann nur falsche sachen sagen
und nie richtig legen das bin ich ein
bisschen irreführend
wer kann was sagst du dazu also es gibt
so einen berühmten satz oder chef der
bundes aber man sagt man kann zitate nie
ohne den kontext an wänden und man kann
auch eine person kein spotlight geben
oder den kontext das heißt wenn ich
dieser person auch wenn wir nur über das
wetter reden
spotlight gebe und sie aber abseits von
unserer wetter diskussion sehr
gefährliche sachen verbreitet dann ob
ich das will oder nicht es ist
scheißegal gebe ich auch dieser seite
der person also ich mache die person
berühmte und unterstützt damit ich
unterstütze damit indirekt oder direkt
wir auch diese seite der personen
was würdest du denn sagen wurde da eine
grenze überschritten wo ist die grenze
und wer entscheidet des senders
menschenverachtende meinungen und die um
positionen gibt dann sollten sie ein
paar kleine bühne gegeben werden es soll
einfach so sein wenn menschen anderen
schmerzen zufügen wollen dann müssen wir
das als gesellschaft als rote linie
sehen auf basis des grundgesetzes oder
wie kann man das heißt machen also
grundgesetz ist da und das ist schon
also ein maßstab aber wir haben die
geschichte auch um uns diese maßstäbe zu
geben
das heißt dass na klar ist die
geschichte wird nie 141 auch wiederholt
aber es gibt muster und diese muster
kann hier anerkennen also ja wenn eine
person also einer der sagt oh ja wir
müssten tieren gut behandeln und er ist
gern bis zwar eine meinung die ich auch
vertrete oder ich denke mir ja gute
meinung aber trotzdem gibt es dahinter
auch eine gesamte ideologie kannst du
das verstehen stammt so dazu also ich
sehe also das was ihr gerade gesagt habe
ich sehe eure sorge also also wenn
es kontroverse personen gibt dann
riskiert man natürlich dass man ihnen
vielleicht eine plattform gibt und dass
vielleicht dann die eine oder andere
fragen würdige meinung oder sowas
gepusht wird aber man muss hier immer
wider abwägen so quasi können wir
sozusagen dieses risiko eingehen dass
das passiert dass man dafür im ausgleich
eine freiere debattenkultur hat und ich
sage dass es hier auch gar keine
eindeutige richtige antwort gibt wenn
man jetzt so zu der seine eigene sendung
betreibt dann kann dann kann man das so
selbst entscheiden und sagen ja ich
möchte diese personen nicht einladen
würde ich möchte sie einladen aber ich
finde wenn die man zu quasi bock hat mit
solchen leuten zu reden und sich für das
gewisse peres kontroverse perspektiven
interessiert da sollte man nicht sagen
oh es ist es ist mein prinzip dass ich
solche mit solchen leuten nicht reden
deswegen musst du das jetzt auch
übernehmen und du darfst jetzt auch
nicht mit solchen leuten richtig mit
ganz offen
meist wird ganz auf das kontroverse
meinungen für ein gewisses klientel weil
wir würden niemals darüber diskutieren
ob jetzt ja mgs terrorist oder ein
islamist oder so hier mit uns diskutiert
würden auch nicht darüber diskutieren ob
wir jetzt mit jemandem reden
er sagt alle weißen menschen gerne
abgeschlachtet oder so dass darüber
diskutiert man die fakten nicht gewahrt
es passiert ja jetzt passiert nicht wenn
mir ein beispiel wo jemals in so einer
person die so eine position hat in
irgendeiner form seiner sendung gefällt
das überhaupt nicht aber das ja wenn du
immer von grants arbeit und springen ist
geht immer nur um eine gewisse gruppen
und gewisse person das ist ein code um
menschenverachtende und
demokratiefeindliche dinge zu
legitimieren ja ich würde gerne aber
auch nochmal zum konkreten beispiel
kommen weil mir ist in den letzten
wochen aufgefallen das hat mich
persönlich sehr beschäftigt dass heute
eigentlich nach jeder folge die wir hier
bei 13 tagen veröffentlichen zum thema
abtreibung prostitution heute zum thema
identitätspolitik es kommen immer
kommentare von menschen die sagen sie
finden es grundsätzliche setzten zitat
menschenverachtend
abtreibungsgegnerinnen einzuladen
sie finden es grundsätzlich
menschenverachtend prostitutions gegner
ihnen sage ich jetzt mal menschen die
dagegen sind einzuladen und das hat mich
zum nachdenken gebracht weil ich mir
denke wir leben in einer demokratie
gehört da nicht meinungsvielfalt dazu
können sie nicht identitätspolitik auch
so weit führen dass ein
eine meinung also eine seite auf dem
feld grundsätzlich nicht mehr akzeptiert
wird
toleranz also demokratische gesellschaft
denn duschen können nicht alle meinungen
bilden nicht die undemokratische
meinungen das ist ein paradoxer wo die
trennlinie ist die rote linie ist ist
natürlich schwierig zu sagen es gibt
einige demokratische ansichten sondern
es kann sein dass unter diesem video zu
diesem heutigen thema steht lautet kein
rassist neues sei es sei mensch es sei
menschenverachtend dass ihr überhaupt
hier auf dieser seite steht und sollten
keine menschen gehabt sagen
identitätspolitik ich zitiere
identitätspolitik sollte grundsätzlich
nicht zur debatte gestellt werden weil
es geht da um um rechte und
menschenrechte und gleichberechtigung
kämpfen
das sollte grundsätzlich nicht zur
diskussion da muss man ein bisschen
differenzieren wenn es jetzt um
identitätspolitik geht dann spricht man
ja darüber wie im detail versuchen
diskriminierte oder benachteiligte
menschen sich hörbar zu machen wie das
passieren kann
da gibt es vielleicht ein paar wege aber
dass diese leute diskriminiert sind das
ist menschen diskriminiert sind und
darüber haben da haben wir angefangen
wir haben angefangen bei strukturell
benachteiligten gruppen dass die
gerechtigkeit brauchen gehör brauchen
ist glasklar wer da anfangen zu reden da
können wir gerne diesen menschen gar
nicht ein land das jetzt von
prostitution und abtreibung gesprochen
beispiele in denen ich mich nicht
besonders auskenne
aber sobald hier und wir standen nämlich
immer wieder beim thema rassismus sobald
hier ein fdp politiker eingeladen ist
ist es für mich auf jeden fall
menschenverachtend ich finde klar wir
müssen uns nichts vormachen in
irgendeiner form geben die alle in
irgendeiner form wir sind nicht perfekt
wir rechnen und einer form immer so und
moralische normen sind auch konventionen
die diskutiert und ehrungen sind man
möchte nämlich immer so eine
freistellung oder so ein ding sie
erklären wir jetzt mal die regeln und
was ist wenn jemandem viertels schwarz
ist es zählt es dann auch und darf ich
dann den einen nicht man muss es leider
immer wieder einzeln ausdiskutieren
herausfinden wie wir stehen mir zur
abtreibung wie finden wie können wir uns
weiterbilden wie können wir sanieren
wir haben es uns jetzt durch einen
philosophischen diskurs durch
menschenrechte geschafft herauszufinden
rassismus ist kacke dafür haben wir
darauf haben wir uns jetzt schon
geeinigt es historisch und das haben wir
heraus
christoph wir sind vielleicht noch nicht
an dem punkt dass wir sagen tiere essen
ist kacke vielleicht kommen wir da hin
und irgendwann haben wir einen konsens
dass wir sagen diese leute die sagen
wenn ich mir ein
da sind wir gerade nicht vielleicht sind
wir moralisch nicht weit genug klima ist
komplett neu für uns wir lernen erst
gerade was das bedeutet wie man sich
verhält aber das heißt ich bin kein
besserer mensch vielleicht habe ich noch
viel mehr dreck am stecken weil ich
jeden tag schnitzel essen und trotzdem
antirassistisch arbeite aber vielleicht
schaffen wir es durch einen diskurs dass
man sich auch dafür schämt oder dass man
auch das gefühl packen wir jetzt alle
gemerkt das ist kacke oder auch nicht
ich weiß wir müssen die argumente
austauschen was wir alles erstmal
ausdiskutieren müssen das versuchen wir
hier haben wir ein bisschen versucht
jetzt gerade mit dieser diskussion
und deswegen kommen wir zu den
kompromissen die sind eigentlich das
beste beispiel für das gemeinsam
ausdiskutieren weil ihr könnt gleich
gemeinsam die köpfe zusammenstecken und
kompromissvorschläge formulieren für die
andere seite aber dazu gleich mehr
erst habe ich ein kompromissvorschlag
für euch und mal gucken ob ihr einen
schritt auf mich zu geht die erste frage
von 13 fragen
wir sollten in allen debatten vor allem
wieder zu hören weil wir vielleicht
nicht dieselbe erfahrung gemacht haben
wie unsere gegenüber es sollte nicht nur
darum gehen recht zu haben oder sich
selbst gerecht und elitär überlegen über
den anderen zu stellen stimmt ihr zu ja
ok alle sind ein schritt auf mich
zugegangen
ach ja eine ganz normale beziehung
gesellschaft
okay dann haben wir gleich gerne bessere
kompromiss vorschläge formulieren wenn
euch welche einschalten
[Musik]
man sagt ja vielleicht ist so dass
teilweise stoppen und ganz regierte
sagen sagen ja ja aber ich glaube auch
dass mein lieblings was und jetzt seid
ihr dran habt ihr noch einen guten
kompromiss vorschlag schreibt gerne mal
eine kommentare das ist es zu finden
was ist ein neuer kompromissvorschlag an
das grüne feld liebes team in grün
unser kompromissvorschlag wäre
identitätspolitik ja definitiv ist es
sehr wichtig für unsere gesellschaft
aber keine langfristige lösung
irgendwann müssten wir da aussteigen
oder auf die bremse drücken wenn das
irgendwann ist wo gleichberechtigung vor
allem übergangs können hier nach china
aufgebaut aufgebrochen sind wenn die
unterdrückung systeme aufgebrochen sind
ein bitte ja also ihr seid alle ein
schritt auf die andere seite zu gelangen
dann seid ihr dran das ist ein
kompromissvorschlag also wir hatten
wirklich wenn eine person ihre identität
betont um auf ihre diskriminierung
aufmerksam zu machen dann tut sie keine
anderen personen weh sondern sie
versucht sich selber zu emanzipieren
ich stimme dir dazu und dafür ist aber
ein einer ein wunsch von euch nicht
unbedingt immer also es gibt leute die
ihre identität betonen und sagen nur ich
darf dazu etwas sagen weil ich sondern
der werker die betonen sie mit dem zweck
ihre diskriminierung zu bekämpfen
gegeben dass wir der person glauben und
den nicht lügen unterstellen sondern sie
werden diskriminiert und sie müssen es
benennen und wie kann ich das benennen
ich muss sagen der typ hat mich gerade
direkt ist ein wort genannt dazu muss
ich sagen wenn du nur meine stimme ist
ich bin schwarz deswegen hat er mich so
genannt aus diesem grund bezieht er
seine identität um gegen seine
diskriminierung zu kämpfen also geht er
einen schritt darauf zu könnt ihr das
verstehen also ich weiß nicht ob er
ihren einwand ausgemerzt hat irgendwie
ich verstehe auch ihr könnt ihr eure
kompromiss man die ganze sache nur beim
namen nennen sogar sagen das ist eine
beschreibung also wenn ich sexismus auf
die straße erlebe das ist schon klar
dass ich als frau und das label aber das
ist keine identitätspolitik das ist eine
beschreibung der der tatsache das ist
keine politik politik ist wenn ich für
umwelt
gesagt man muss es beschreiben man muss
es betont es wurde keine begrifflichkeit
verwendet er meinte nur man muss als
frau sagen das war sexistisch dass es
mir passiert weil ich eine frau bin ja
genau
stimmst du dazu ja klar aber das ist
dann kann ich ja aber es ist eine sache
auf die ihr euch schon reinigen könnt
besser als nicht ich habe mich an
manchen stellen viel nahe an andere
leute in der anderen gruppe gefühlt aber
an mancher stelle nicht also die sage
sind viel komplizierter als zwei kisten
auf jeden fall wir haben uns auch
tatsächlich im kreis gedreht manchmal
ich finde an sich die fragestellung
schon ein bisschen schwierig für mich
ist klingt wie klingt brauchen wir
identitätspolitik klingt für mich wie
brauchen wir in der repräsentanz für
marginalisierte gruppen und da ist
natürlich die antwort ja brauchen wir
auf jeden fall
ich wünsche mir dass man dass man zu
einem punkt kommt wo die gegenseite
nicht zu starken dämonisiert wird und
man wohlwollend in eine diskussion
reingeht und denke dass er sozusagen
auch gutes im sinne hat und nicht so ja
der gehört der afg an und deswegen ist
ein schlechter mensch und solche
geschichten also es ist es kann
natürlich sein dass er falsche ansichten
hat es seit gar nichts damit zu tun also
wie gesagt ich kenne das aus meiner
eigenen familie ich hab' ich hatte einen
großvater der rechtsextremistischen
ansichten hat ein sehr engagiert in der
politik war und der war ein super lieber
opa ich habe ihn nie als teufel gesehen
aber fakt ist er hatte ansichten die
eben dazu führen könnten dass gesamte
gesellschaftlichen gruppen auch
vernichtet werden
das akzeptiere ich nicht so ein bisschen
hätte ich auch gerne gelernt was kann
man vielleicht besser machen und was
sind so dinge wo du sagst hey da konkret
die art und weise wie menschen in
anschluss sanitäts politik machen das
würde ich anders machen oder verbessern
ich glaube es ist voll wichtig dass
selbst wenn wir debattieren einfach
nehmen dann dastehen können und uns auch
die hand reichen können und das ist so
etwas was vor allem im online geschehen
so total krass wegfällt und ich wünsche
mir halt dass wir so viel
vielmehr so gesündere austauschplattform
haben wie zum beispiel auch dieses
format muss ich mir auch für dich auf
zeit
also ist klar nur weil ihr euch jetzt
alle sehr nahe steht seit ihr euch nicht
in allem ein nicht also für das glaube
ich alle nach dieser diskussion sicher
es ist noch viel offen wir müssen aber
noch sehr viel mehr darüber diskutieren
und sprechen und deswegen danke euch
dass ihr dieses eine mal mit dabei war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
falls euch diese folge gefallen hat und
bestenfalls zum nachdenken angeregt hat
dann freue ich mich sehr über ein abo
auf diesem kanal und wenn ihr ein
weiteres video zu dem thema den wald
guckt doch gar nicht hier oben nach und
hier gibt es ein weiteres video von 13
fragen